[Musique]
Hélène buzetti à la question gay
Christian Dufour bonsoir
bonsoir révélation troublante donc dans
le hockey junior 19 joueurs qui
voulaient un recours collectif contre la
Ligue de hockey junior canadienne
l'ensemble de la Ligue 19 joueurs qui
ont joué dans 38 équipes je rappelle ce
chiffre-là parce que c'est pas une
exception dans une équipe là ils se sont
promenée et on constaté et ont été
l'objet de harcèlement de viol même de
d'agressions etc je vous fais entendre
quelques réactions politiques et on
revient tout de suite
mon message est clair aujourd'hui les
initiations doivent cesser dans toutes
les stages en entendu pas je sors à qui
j'en ai entendu dans d'autres sports des
initiations comme ça c'est de l'abus
c'est des mauvais traitements ça doit
être interdit puis j'invite pas j'invite
mais je demande à tous les adultes qui
sont impliqués dans le sport de mettre
un terme à ça c'est facile à changer là
c'est facile à arrêter ça maintenant
c'est pas toléré ni par les adultes dans
le sport ni par les organisations faut
que ça je regarde tous les moyens à ma
disposition pour intervenir dans ce
genre de situation là puis pour prévenir
les abus puis les mauvais traitement de
façon générale dans le sport
c'est beau la notion d'empathie ça prend
des actions il faut libérer la parole
des gens il faut que les gens soient
imputables de leurs actions
particulièrement effectivement les
personnes qui étaient en autorité puis
qui ont pas réagi c'est pour ça qu'une
commission d'enquête publique
indépendante va faire la lumière puis va
faire la différence pour qu'on puisse
comme gouvernement comme législateurs
apporter des actions
comme comme tout le monde je pense que
ça m'a glacé le sang vous savez ça fait
plus de 45 ans que j'évolue dans le
milieu sportif et je n'ai jamais vu je
n'ai jamais lu je n'ai jamais été témoin
je n'ai jamais
soupçonné qu'il y a des gestes de d'une
telle ampleur il doit y avoir un
protocole des mesures qui sont mises en
place pour assurer l'intégrité des
athlètes
bon Hélène elle est Christian une même
question est-ce que le politique doit
s'en mêler est-ce qu'on doit exiger
comme dilaminer du Québec un protocole
qui a des que des garde-fous pour
arrêter ces dérives et ses agressions
je sais pas écouter tout ceci est
proprement révoltant le genre fond on
serait pas une porte ouverte il y a
période absolument rien excusable
là-dedans la question que je me pose par
contre c'est si on fait pas fausse route
en pensant que c'est propre au milieu du
hockey la ministre le mentionné on l'a
entendu des fois dans d'autres sports
mais aussi dans le milieu militaire dans
le milieu univers universitaire aussi
écoutez il y a même une page Wikipédia
qui recense les décès aux États-Unis
suivant des initiations à l'université
rappelez-vous qu'en 2016 quand on avait
entendu parler d'initiation ou des
femmes sur des jeunes femmes se
retrouvaient carrément nues le
gouvernement Couillard à l'époque avait
dû intervenir pour dire ça suffit les
initiations alors moi je pense que le
problème est beaucoup plus large et il
interpelle cette capacité phénoménale de
l'humain de se déresponsabiliser de ses
actes dès lors qu'ils se trouvent dans
un groupe et c'est ça qui est proprement
et renversant et on voit que ça
s'applique dans plein d'autres
circonstances récemment à Toronto là ces
jeunes filles qui ont attaqué un
sans-abri et l'ont tué huit jeunes
filles très très jeune alors je pense
que le problème est beaucoup plus large
que seulement ce qu'on appelle une
certaine masculinité toxique dans le
hockey
le problème est certainement plus large
mais il y a un problème en particulier
au hockey il y a un problème en
particulier on le met avec OK Canada on
le voit avec les légumes junior il y a
une culture de la testostérone du
machisme de la violence qui est tolérées
depuis longtemps ces initiations là
existent depuis très longtemps
d'ailleurs vous regardez le premier
plaignant qui demandera quoi collectif a
terminé son hockey junior en 1982 le
dernier en 2014 c'est 50 ans le presque
de de de d'abus là on parle pas juste
d'abus d'humiliation on parle le juge
parle de torture c'est quand même pas
rien on parle de jeunes de 16 17 ans qui
ont été torturés par des collègues
parfois il y avait des entraîneurs qui
étaient présents qui ont participé qui
ont toléré que ça se produise donc
quelque chose qui se passe avec leur qui
je pense doit être vidé de sa question
est-ce que c'est une enquête publique
comme le réclame le Bloc québécois je
suis moins certain parce que c'était des
mineurs au moment des faits ils ont
droit à l'anonymat parce qu'ils étaient
mineurs vont-ils vouloir venir témoigner
quelque chose autour de sexuelle qui est
délicat de mettre quelqu'un devant le
public comme ça mais d'abord une enquête
qui soit faite soit par la commissaire à
l'intégrité du sport un nouvel organisme
mis en place à Ottawa sur nous avons un
conseiller spécial qui qui regarde ce
qu'on peut faire qui parle au ligue pour
qu'on a juste les règlements qu'on
interdit ce genre de pratique là je
pense le gouvernement doit s'en mêler
est-ce qu'elle forme ça doit prendre
certains c'est un lieu de regarder mais
je pense le gouvernement doit faire un
pas de plus pour envoyer le message que
là faut que ça change là il y a des
limites à ce qu'on peut tolérer en
termes de sociétés est-ce que le
politique doit son armer les Christian
oui je suis d'accord que c'est allait
tellement loin qu'on peut penser que le
politique devrait s'en mêler mais mais
de quelle façon comme le dit avec les
initiations c'est très très ancien en
fait moi je suis les années 60 à
l'Université Laval quand j'ai fait mon
droit on nous parlait que on allait se
faire initier mais là ça prend une telle
ampleur qu'on doit se poser la question
est-ce que ça a toujours été comme ça
puis on le savait pas où est-ce que
vraiment ça c'est cette accentué dans la
période plus moi aussi je pense que le
domaine du hockey on peut penser que
étant donné le statut que le hockey dans
notre société au Canada au Québec
iconique que c'est un domaine qui est
plus préservé parce que ce que troublant
entre autres c'est pas juste des abus à
l'égard des jeunes joueurs mais c'est
l'espèce de complaisance même
d'approbation par les personnes en
position c'est ça qui est troublant et
le dernier témoignage rapporté ça
remonte à 2014 donc depuis 2014 fait 9
ans c'est pas long 9 ans mais en même
temps depuis 9 ans il est arrivé
beaucoup de choses dans le domaine des
agressions de toutes sortes donc on peut
espérer que ça soit que ça soit amélioré
sauf que les responsables sont
vraisemblablement toujours encore là
donc moi je pense qu'on va avoir une
enquête pour voir est-ce que vraiment il
y a quelque chose de nouveau qui est
arrivé mais de fin toutes les
initiations attendons parce qu'il y
avait des initiations assez anodines en
définitive bon il y a toutes sortes
c'est vraiment dans la culture de de nos
sociétés depuis très très longtemps
c'est une façon en fait d'initier les
nouveaux qui arrivent mais là on voit
que ça prend une dimension quand même
surréaliste incroyable en fait ce qu'on
lui dit aujourd'hui oui enfermer des
gens pendant des heures dans une
toilette d'autobus faire avec
une bâton de hockey là c'est pas
nous on faisait couper les cheveux à
l'époque là ça à la limite coupé cheveux
très bien mais
il y a toute cette notion de développer
l'esprit de corps c'est ça l'idée de
d'une initiation c'est de un esprit
d'équipe un esprit de corps mais là
cette expliquant jusqu'où on le pousse
et pourquoi surtout pourquoi veut-on
amener un groupe à se rallier à une
telle pratique et garder ça entre eux
c'est ça aussi peut-être aussi une des
interventions qui pourraient être faite
mais certainement pas la seule là mais
c'est de de joindre aux inscriptions aux
destinées aux parents même un message
aux jeunes dire si vous avez des
initiations qui qui dépassent les bonnes
vous avez le droit de ne pas être
d'accord et surtout il faut dénoncer
donc
crever la bulle finalement faire en
sorte qu'ils sortent de cet
environnement une remarque qui est pas
du tout politique sociologique en fait
on peut se poser la question comment ça
se fait qu'une critique qu'une culture
pardon aussi macho que la culture du
hockey aussi viril que la culture du
hockey en fait ça pue je suis qu'un
certain point sur des rites
sadomasochiste à connotation
homosexuelle je trouve que pour il y a
tellement de doctorat sur des sujets
fut-il là il y aura une thèse de
doctorat à faire là-dessus qui monte à
quel point c'est complexe la sécurité
mais Hélène j'avais mis un doigt sur
quelque chose de tellement vrai aussi le
groupe devient dangereux des gens en
groupe on l'a vu les études le monde il
y a des gens qui vont aller jusqu'à
torturer puis bon bref mais ça prend des
adultes dans la salle ça prend des
adultes dans la salle cette expérience
de Milgram là qui était fait dans les
années 60 mais repos conduite là on
demande à un sujet de faire un choc
électrique à un cobaye qui évidemment un
comédien mais le sujet ne le sait pas et
et dans 80% des cas les gens vont
continuer à administrer les chocs
électriques au niveau de l'ordre du
supportable il y a quelque chose dans
l'esprit humain de cette capacité de se
dissocier de ces actes dès lors que
quelqu'un d'autre vous demande de le
faire ok les provinces qui ont accepté
discrètement on va écouter madame
Stevenson
l'offre du fédéral ils avaient dit on va
se voir lundi et ils acceptent tout ça
pour pour ça j'allais dire mais ils
acceptent en écoute
United
tour de table rapide je commence avec
vous Christian parce qu'on en a beaucoup
beaucoup parlé c'est un peu la fin d'un
épisode puis peut-être le début d'un
autre Christian on sent pas beaucoup
d'enthousiasme on dit très loin de la
période que j'ai connu à l'époque que
j'étais conseiller en relation fédérale
provinciale où on disait il suffit que
le Québec est l'Ontario s'entendent
fermement sur un dossier et fédéral pas
d'autres choix que de plier on va que
dans ce domaine-là les provinces sont
proposés c'est le fédéral qui dispose et
c'est un dossier qui n'intéresse pas à
ce point-là le citoyen ordinaire parce
que c'est un dossier technique donc
déception de la part des provinces mais
elle n'avait pas vraiment le choix je
pense ok rapidement donc Hélène
j'espère que vous reteniez pas votre
souffle pas triste non c'est assez
évident que ils allaient accepter cet
argent
4.6 milliards par année le pour donner
un ordre de grandeur les provinces les
10 provinces ensemble vont dépasser
cette année seulement à peu près 200
milliards alors ça donne une autre un
ordre de grandeur mais je pense que la
raison pour laquelle ils acceptent c'est
que le montant est bien en deçà de ce
qu'il vous demandait certes mais en
contrepartie les conditions qu'on
craignait ne sont pas aussi
contraignantes finalement et donc on se
dit bah tout prendre on va quand même
prendre l'argent 4.6 milliards c'est
quand même mieux
ils ont pas vraiment le choix parce que
c'est pas une vraie négo avec
non c'est un transfert unilatéral en
santé on l'oublie mais il y a pas
vraiment de négociation c'est un
programme fédéral puis Ottawa disait que
les conditions c'est ce qui fait en
sorte qu'on n'avait pas beaucoup de
levier de négociation pour les provinces
la formule actuelle elle est quand même
meilleure c'est ce qui fait en sorte
qu'on rentre dans le rang assez
rapidement et un peu plus d'argent il y
a pas de conditions le transfert va
augmenter au minimum de 5% par année
bref c'est mieux que ce que c'était mais
on a tellement demandé beaucoup du côté
des provinces qui inévitablement en
termes de d'apparence d'opinion publique
c'est assez clair qu'elle sorte perdante
de ce très court pourra te faire qui
aura duré quoi deux trois heures en
réalité préparez vos analyses on écoute
Gabriel ado Dubois une trentaine de
secondes on revient tout de suite au
terme de son conseil national
il faut aussi aller à la rencontre des
électeurs à l'essor des centres urbains
pour leur demander comment on lutte avec
vous contre les changements climatiques
comment notre plan de lutte au
changement climatique peut être le plus
rassembleur possible il faut trouver ce
point d'équilibre là entre l'ambition en
matière climatique ça il faut qu'on
reste ambitieux on n'a pas le choix tout
en s'assurant d'avoir des mesures
écologiques qui rassemble le plus grand
nombre si on avait trouvé ce point
d'équilibre là à la dernière élection on
aurait sans doute emporté
comment mieux vendre son programme en
région c'est un des thèmes alors alex je
commence avec vous concernational vos
premières impressions
ouais bah il y a beaucoup de paix sur la
planche pour Québec solidaire pour
essayer de percer dans les endroits
difficiles notamment les régions
ressources je voudrais qu'il y a
beaucoup de pain sur la planche pour
tous les parties d'opposition quand on
regarde la carte mise à part la
coalition avec table rase dans les
régions du Québec c'est difficile pour
les libéraux c'est difficile pour le PQ
parce que les deux comptes comptés en
région sont largement tributaires de
ceux qui sont en place mais qui sont
très très connus dans leur coin et c'est
difficile pour Québec donc ils ont tous
un examen de confiance conscience à
faire sur comment on fait pour aller
joindre ses électeurs là ceci dit Québec
solidaire en images plus associée au
centre urbain depuis sa naissance depuis
sa création en raison des sujets qu'il
porte en raison des porte-parole qu'il a
depuis le début aussi la création de
Québec solidaire donc le travail est
peut-être un petit peu plus complexe ils
ont 4 ans pour réfléchir à comment y
arriver mais oui c'est une grande
question on comment on fait pour amener
des électeurs de régions ressources
j'aime pas le mot région parce que les
territoires du Québec sont tous
différents mais des endroits où on a
effectivement pas les mêmes
préoccupations concentrées
qui a remportait Christian oui je pense
que deux éléments positifs en fin de
semaine c'est à dire que solidaire et
n'est plus dans le déni par rapport aux
résultats de la dernière élection ils
sont confrontés un peu un mur comme le
dit Paul Chaudet dans la presse ce matin
vous aussi il y a pas eu chicken en fin
de semaine avec la France radicale du
parti qui peut être très idéologique
farouchement en capitaliste parfois
anti-ébécois moi je crois par ailleurs
que Québec Solidaire a un gros gros
problème et je pense pas que le problème
de Québec solidaire c'est avec tes
régions du Québec le problème de Québec
solidaire c'est avec le Québec lui-même
c'est que Québec solidaire ne
s'intéresse pas vraiment aux
problématiques spécifiquement
québécoise en fait quand on parle de
langue ça les intéresse pas à ce
point-là quand on passe d'immigration et
on approche qui peut faire un petit peu
surréaliste ils sont pas vraiment
nationalistes ils sont pas
souverainistes leur crédibilité
souveraineté c'est à peu près nul on
sait que la majorité de supporters de
Québec solidaire seront pas
souverainistes Paul Saint-Pierre par
Mondon alors on fait de leur donc Québec
solidaire en fait ce qu'ils veulent
c'est qu'ils sont pour sauver la planète
pour l'ouverture pour la diversité pour
la parité mais le Québec réel y a un
gros problème avec le Québec réel et
c'est pas juste les régions c'est
beaucoup plus profond que ça et juste
terminé ils sont populaires chez les
jeunes c'est vrai mais les jeunes
vieillissent ce moment donné Hélène
conclusion
j'ajouterai je pense que cette question
de bonus malus sur les voitures qui leur
a fait mal beaucoup pendant la campagne
je ne pense pas que c'est un thème
nécessairement perdant pour eux je pense
que c'est surtout un thème qu'on ne peut
pas amener en campagne électorale c'est
trop compliqué il faut l'annoncer avant
parce que s'il y a beaucoup de détails à
exposer et moi je donne souvent le le
parallèle avec Justin Trudeau en 2015
qui avait annoncé plusieurs mois à
l'avance sa fameuse stratégie de
modulation de l'impôt taxer les plus
riches pour redonner au classe moyenne
ça avait été compliqué donc il y avait
pris quelques temps pour l'expliquer et
ça avait fait ça ça marque de commerce
politique pour l'élection je pense que
Québec solidaire pourrait faire une
telle chose un bonus malus ça fait des
années qu'on en parle d'autres pays
français et vous en parliez en début
d'émission avec l'augmentation des vies
il va falloir qu'on s'y attaquer à un
moment donné alors c'est pas
nécessairement perdant mais c'est la
manière qu'on le fait si prendre tôt
puis expliquer expliquer et pas non plus
laisser tomber nos ce à quoi on croit
merci beaucoup à vous trois bons retours
Christian merci au revoir à très bientôt
au revoir